throughout the Halloween franchise the
timeline diverges multiple times and the
main series even features one entry
without Michael Myers but we're here to
help sort through it all so grab your
favorite carving knife and let's dig in
this is Michael Myers backstory
explained the story of Michael Myers
begins on Halloween night in 1963 in the
Suburban town of Haddonfield Illinois as
six-year-old Michael gets up walks into
his sister's room and stabs her to death
Michael is sent to Smith's Grove
sanitarium where he spends the rest of
his childhood and Adolescence he has
observed and studied by Dr Sam Loomis
who winds up becoming an expert on the
man the myth the legend that is Michael
Myers
on October 30th 1978 the story of
Michael Myers begins in Earnest he
escapes from Smith's Grove the Night
Before Halloween and descends upon
Haddonfield meanwhile high schooler Lori
Strode played by Jamie Lee Curtis in her
first film role is preparing for a
boring Halloween night babysitting young
Tommy Doyle near the Mars home which is
now abandoned instead of having a dull
Knight earning a little money on the
side Lori ends up at the tail end of
Michael's Killing Spree after a night of
tracking Michael Loomis comes to the
house where Lori is fighting him off and
manages to put Six Bullets in the Killer
Halloween 2 picks up later that night
when Lori is brought to the Haddonfield
Memorial Hospital where Michael
reappears to finish what he started the
sequel begins what would become a major
expansion of the Halloween lore by
revealing that Lori is Michael's sister
according to Halloween 2 Lori was taken
in and raised by the strodes this
explains why Michael is so dead set on
killing Lori as he wants to finish what
he started Halloween 2 ends with Michael
being presumed dead when there's a fire
at the hospital
the third movie in the franchise
Halloween three Season of the Witch was
an experiment that tried to take the
franchise in an anthology Direction and
away from Michael Myers after lukewarm
reviews the series fell into limbo for
years after it returned with 1988's
Halloween for the return of Michael
Myers it never again strayed from the
unfeeling killer at its core Halloween 4
stars Danielle Harris as Jamie Lloyd
Lori strode's daughter Jaime is living
with a foster family and has recurring
dreams of Michael coming together those
dreams turn out to be warnings when
Michael wakes up from a 10-year coma and
goes after his closest living relative
the movie ends in a standoff near an
abandoned mine but only after depicting
a moment of psychic connection initially
established via physical contact with
Jaime in the final moments of Halloween
4 the family returns home Jamie eerily
wearing a similar costume to the one
Michael wore all the way back in 1963.
just whenever everyone thinks they're
safe Jaime attacks her foster mother and
reappears at the top of the stairs
holding a bloody pair of scissors Dr
Loomis tries to shoot her but is sorted
as Halloween 5 the Revenge of Michael
Myers begins Jaime is mute and in a
psychiatric hospital after attempting to
kill her foster mother this is implied
to be the result of a moment she shared
with Michael in the previous movie
sparking a connection that leaves Jaime
suffering hallucinations that keep her
bond with Michael shrouded in mystery in
the curse of Michael Myers Michael
returns to his childhood home to kill
the Strode family that now lives there
Tommy Doyle now an adult lives across
the street
my name's Tommy
I was only eight years old when I saw
him
Doyle has been studying Michael and has
discovered that the root of his evil is
an ancient Druid curse known as Thorne
this brings the family connection full
circle as the conditions of the curse
say The Afflicted must kill their next
of kin on Halloween night
made 20 years after the original
Halloween H2O 20 years later brought
Jamie Lee Curtis back for a story
pitched as a direct sequel to Halloween
2. this movie returns Michael's
motivations to the roots with him
specifically trying to find and kill
Laurie Strode H2O brings Michael from
Haddonfield to California where Lori has
built a new identity and life for
herself as a school teacher however he's
foiled again with what looks like the
most definitive Michael kill yet when
Lori Chomps off his head with a fire ax
in an unexpected turn Halloween
resurrection reveals that the ending of
H2O was an illusion of course the
decapitated man wasn't Michael instead
Lori killed an innocent man and now has
been institutionalized honey you come
for me sooner or later despite Lori's
best lead traps Michael breaks into the
sanitarium where she's being held she's
about to kill him but begins to Grapple
with his mask to make sure it's the real
Michael that doubt gives Michael enough
time to stab and finally kill Lori
tossing her off the roof and that's only
the beginning of Resurrection Michael
goes on yet another Killing Spree aided
in part by Busta Rhymes and Tyra Banks
Yes you heard that right Lori's death
could have been a huge moment in the
Halloween Cannon but it finally left the
franchise nowhere to go but back to the
beginning
in 2007 the franchise returned thanks to
Rob Zombie who directed a remake of the
original 1978 Carpenter Classic this
poorly received installment more or less
retold the story of the first movie but
many felt it didn't hold a candle to the
original zombie followed up his remake
with his own version of Halloween 2 set
two years after the events in
Haddonfield Lori begins having
hallucinations in which she sees herself
acting out Michael's past murders Laurie
manages to actually kill Michael after
stabbing him with his own knife Laurie
puts on his mask and becomes the new
Michael Myers
with the 2018 reimagining of Halloween
the series went back to basics giving
viewers a direct sequel to 1978's
Halloween and disregarding the big twist
connecting Lori and Michael in Halloween
2. in this timeline Michael has been
incarcerated for the past 40 years for
the killings he committed in the very
first movie he breaks out to track down
and kill Lori who in this continuity is
definitely not his sister over the years
Laurie has become a reclusive alcoholic
who's very good at setting traps for
Michael it pays off because a traps She
lays for him sets her house Ablaze with
Michael presumably dead inside but with
sequel's Halloween kills and Halloween
ends announced shortly after that
movie's release it was soon clear that
Michael also survived that fire and
lived to kill again check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
Looper videos about your favorite horror
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]